how are you my guy love ya
you walked right into it what did you
get in yesterday
yeah just kind of around my piece um
that's what's up well yeah well
basically we [ __ ] with your music bro
straight up just that's what it is and
so Gary [ __ ] with your music I don't
know if you've seen like in-between I
didn't see I'm getting [ __ ] killed on
social media I'm trying but a missing
[ __ ] I was see I'm glad dim moment and
then like you know I went in as
interesting about you just like a over
with the DJ cutthroat tape all my kids
and write this [ __ ] you're talking about
grows like so personal and like you will
get motivated right maybe feel your pain
but then it's like melodic and you get
both you better you're motivating people
right so it's like there's so many
synergies here and then I was watching
this interview recently we're used to
you did you were bias these 50 cents
no no so that 205 I saw that new thing
there that's so cool is like one thing
into my life spot it's like flipping
baseball cards as a kid right all right
and this whole setup is really just a
conversation to get to know each other
like see what's up and all that but one
thing I need to say is that out of
people in Atlanta like you know he's the
man
I know what's going also yeah right oh
yeah how old are you
it's the best right now these [ __ ]
kids in the project coming Friday but he
had a lot of work like projects coming
it's just a good time how are you how
are you guys thinking as a team like
what's what's like when you're this
young in this part of the process
there's always the micro and the macro
whenever I meet artists
maybe I find it guilt and they tell it
whatever they could hear what was their
screams and I used on footage scripts
anybody do they part know something
never called me now they're taking
picture of me if they might do they part
and they'll be good the same way the guy
only got a baseball bat to face why I
receive left tackle what about what's
what's your perspective on all and he
has big aspirations you know coming from
his background and what he's gone
through he's able to just put a lot of
stuff together so it's not just music a
lot of it is real estate making sure
that the community is taken care of
leaving a stamp leave no marks of the
world a better place where he is like
where all is not just about the music
we're always about improving their lives
he takes care of a lot of people yeah
the significant ways a lot of positivity
gratitude which the absent he talks
about but then the Union gives out free
food yeah what what do you think you got
a little sense of me and us and him like
what's your point of view no I think
that the big thing is sort of for him
doing it he's on like carving his own
path out of it and just consistency I
think that's one of the big synergies
that you guys have like since we started
working together I worked with me
Michelle he's dropped five projects like
four of his own projects and was the
fourth one coming on Friday and then a
project with his DJ as well I came out
November so he's just consistent he's
only thinking about you know the project
that's coming out in the spring and the
project that will come out in the
stubborn like he's already thinking two
or three steps ahead he's he's in that
he's in that space that you're always
talking about I believe in that she'll
so [ __ ] much I know I don't
understand how people don't see it it's
not [ __ ] 1994 anymore if you've got
it and you put it out technologies on
your side
everybody's just um thank you but I just
don't do it for because of it yeah but
it could be Richard a fer-de-lance
I like ambition sorry I don't know that
that's right Alexa yeah she does she's
not self-aware either yeah man it's I
grew listen I agree with you but I think
the thing that I wish people understood
like something in you and others myself
like somewhere along the line once you
know yourself you got a much better
chance people struggle with knowing who
they are they want to be somebody
everybody everybody had wants to be
something instead of figuring out what
they are and triple down on it I see it
with management a lot in music they want
to be the artist you know you know you
know but it's interesting I have noticed
it a lot I'm like okay I understand that
like that makes sense like happens in
the agency world a lot of my creatives
wanted to make movies you know and so
like I get it it's interesting and I was
just always think about like just wish
people are more self aware of what they
were good at so that the quickest path
to the most upside financially after
everybody can be a millionaire it's
[ __ ] self awareness because once you
know who you are you stop lying to
yourself when you stop lying to yourself
you stop becoming insecure and and all
the [ __ ] that drags you down to not be
motivated to [ __ ] work like I'm so
happy and and like at peace that I could
put all my energy on the [ __ ] and work
like 18 hours a day feels good cuz I'm
happy as [ __ ] doing it it was funny we
like we started chunk of you that's
right
trying to be something if I wanna be
somebody is but we're getting it over
the line today all right he's great
you'll love this I was in the studio for
the first time actually watching a song
be made we were like [ __ ] around a
little bit
literally the first song I'd ever seen
being I'm just not the studio like I'm
doing my thing and what I am I'm doing
business meetings so it's never like
really like we're making a song here's
me he's writing he goes in she goes in
literally the first song I was ever
associated with meaning like just [ __ ]
around with the artist like take it up
stuff I looked at him like holy [ __ ] I
why do people ever leave yeah I would
just make songs every minute that's the
most fun like I would just make a I
would have a million songs I'd be like
why would I even do anything else I'm
serious I think that was [ __ ] public
that's it
that was it I was like okay let's make I
got like I got 19 thousand other things
I got to say that's why I put up so much
content and read all these [ __ ] books
like when you have something to say a
hundred percent and when you could said
[ __ ] mute man yeah when you can do it
with music you can pierce people's soul
and [ __ ] make an impact right it's
what I like about it most at first I was
doing it for my own so other people band
it to me see it I gotta keep doing it so
you telling me what I'm going through
heavy you go through Charlie go through
these land and when I say
yeah we got us some you know go away a
lot of [ __ ] don't come to go ports and
music I'll take you way way back three
people that existed on earth they were
throwing rocks at each other and they
were banging those rocks together that's
just deeply entrenched in us as animals
period is there anything we could help
with in the short term I'm the project
comes out Friday right so we can focus
on that for Monday's list yeah I'll
listen to it carefully okay yeah next
week we'll definitely put like I'll
listen to we'll listen to it over the
weekend put one or two songs on the on
our list on Monday and then we'll put
we'll use some of our social media
content over the next couple of weeks
yeah that's like I want to hear the
other tracks too but I mean what's your
goal bro like what are you trying to do
next month let's gonna go just to come
see other dogs and a push talent push
artist it is just hard as [ __ ] the final
artist it's not it if I'm a person
that's in a spotlight and their skin so
much attention with so much money to be
harmful it's a lot of it wasn't
they just they're so hungry they've been
linked reaming to that moment it just
that's exactly right
well you love this nine put out content
all the time
and I literally verbatim we've got no
because they follow me everywhere people
ask me like why do you put out such your
best content why don't you sell it and
literally my answer is because 99% of
you [ __ ] faces aren't gonna do anything
about it
I give away every one of my secrets
because somewhere along the line I
realized oh my god I'm gonna be loved
and revered because I'm given the
cleanest best [ __ ] advice for free
and it's not gonna hurt me because
nobody's gonna do anything
forget about like it makes me feel good
and I'm making an impact there was a
second part I just thought I was gonna
make an impact that I was gonna feel
good but I was gonna [ __ ] up my
economics it didn't because nobody's
doing anything I'm telling you what to
do - you don't say I'm a survey because
of decent decent dead but see what's
even better what's even better what I
like way more is your first 60 songs you
referenced 13 times that you ain't
signing with no label right like a month
like I was like like that back in the
day I didn't think they had options so
when I got kind of in the last 15 months
I've started like really really paying
attention again to hip-hop and like the
whole culture which is why it like feels
like I'm closer to it these days and so
I was like yeah you know I got back into
it so I listened to a lot of [ __ ]
music I was like okay yeah these young
[ __ ] entrepreneurs they got it yes
they get they don't have to sign they're
gonna be smart they're gonna and then
literally systematically like especially
cuz I was catching up so I've listened
to three projects in a row and literally
projects number one you're talking [ __ ]
like I ain't gonna [ __ ] sign with you
[ __ ] you this is the second when
you like I'm [ __ ] and the third one
you like I sign but it's okay
it's crazy I'm aware man yeah laugh at
people they don't understand like when
you go to the casino you can win the
first time but if you keep going they
didn't build all that pretty [ __ ] what
do you think Michael KITT me wonder
there's math behind this
this isn't like like and then but
everybody loves short term money
everybody wants to put that money to
their ear and post it on Instagram but I
still had a lot of money
I just was able to take my tags then I
was able to say I thought I've given to
gentlemen man they thought I split my
money so it was that one day like oh she
he spent the money cuz there were ever
artists to basically everything yeah
it's just a hundred percent no you know
why because this next album we're gonna
do for that label there's gonna be a
song on there that's gonna make me the
biggest artists in the world that's just
you know see what though I got into the
sports game we're up some football
players I'm like you may never see a
second contract but here's what it is
man it's psychology when you're 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 and you have nothing or
not a lot and you're watching imagery of
a lot of all the stuff on you ran out of
the car like when you see it you want it
it [ __ ] seduces you and so you make
bad long-term decisions if you put that
[ __ ] if you put that watch into the
Amazon and Facebook you could buy the
watch company sure you know it's crazy
now what's great is you've been
fullcycle and you're 25
now you're dangerous the fact that
you've tasted both flavors
the fact that you've been thoughtful
about it now and spent the fact that you
through a full cycle and you're 25 now
you can get dangerous the more [ __ ] you
eat you're so young but you're so
farther along and wise and educated on
how the game goes within another ten is
different about Rollo that most people
is he's like genuine to the sense of
like he trusts you right so it's kind of
like you know some people expected
business I know your business music
something really every bad let me tell
me tell you something that you need to
think about because the way you and I
came up that makes a lot of sense a lot
of these big companies are losing money
every month for market share cuz they
raise the [ __ ] load of money
so a lot of the money I've made in my
life and a lot of the money that
somebody like you could make off that
stuff sometimes when you think I want to
become the Spotify or a mini-version
Spotify and and title for titles losing
money they raised money jay-z didn't
sell his shares to sprint for kicks and
giggles so you're right in the way like
you came up and I came up in a way that
merit like if you actually made money
you got money that Wall Street game
little tricky people make money even
though they're still not making money
you understand cuz they're trying to buy
money you know what they lose you know
what they're trying to do they're trying
to hold their breath and have somebody
else buy them to make their nut but
they're losing every month it's not like
Facebook right and Twitter and uber and
all these companies are investing in
they don't make money
looks like one day they'll make money
and if they do they make real [ __ ]
money
I didn't say Spotify because I don't
know where they're at at this point
they're close but to your point like I
always think about like that person's
making money let me give you something I
know you're gonna understand sometimes
the bank loses when they bet and put out
too much money and it doesn't come back
right so like book deals I do book deals
no different than what you guys do with
music in the game I do them because I
ran the math for them to give me the
dollars up front I know what to do with
the dollars versus how much I sell and
not how much I can make it's just math
you know math I've been listen to
everything you say you haven't said it
but that's how you play so on the
streaming side be careful and like will
not be careful keep in mind when you
start looking under the hood and looking
at the math understand in real venture
capital and private equity and like Wall
Street [ __ ] dynamics sometimes they
take so much money upfront what they're
actually doing is not trying to make
money mm-hmm understand that's right or
what you're doing you buy up a whole
neighborhood in Atlanta you put a lot of
debt behind you and you hope that that's
the next spot and you flip it before you
get the call on your money that's why a
lot of people do go bankrupt and that's
why a lot of people like you and I who
come from zero don't ever go bankrupt
but don't ever also get the forty
billion because we're not willing to go
I'm not willing to go to so when people
I always tell people I'm gonna buy the
Jets people like you're gonna buy the
Jets in three or four years I'm like you
know understand I'm not gonna put myself
in a position to buy the Jets in three
or four years I made by him in 32
because I'm running a marathon I'm not
trying to put my my life in jeopardy to
look it's a bigger version of what you
just said about all those artists
Michael look all cool
I bought 40 acres in here I bought 4,000
apartment buildings I'm [ __ ] great
until you're not it's like all those
kids that bought [ __ ] Bitcoin a month
ago at $17,000
coin maxed out their credit cards
because it was going to 34,000 until it
went to 9 notice how in the last two
weeks people aren't saying the word
Bitcoin as much we'll spend some time
together let's take a quick photo cuz I
got bounce you got we said that man get
me a seat on my please
[Music]